pierre martinet un ancien agent de la
dgse il fondateur de wincor security a
difference bonsoir pierre martinet merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france est la
menace terroriste est élevée on le voit
bien on plaint confinement nationale est
ce que le risque où le risque augmente
ou bien est-ce qu'ils diminuent dans ce
contexte alors bonsoir oui effectivement
le risque terroriste est toujours
présent alors je ne sais pas si ils
augmentent ou diminuent
toutes les forces de police les forces
enfin les forces les les médecins et les
hôpitaux sont son centre est enfin sont
plus que sollicité en ce moment et ça
laisse une porte ouverte pour des
personnes qui pourraient commettre des
attentats islamistes je suis d'ailleurs
étonné qu'il y en ait pas plus en
revanche le projet islamiste a débuté en
1928 est passé au travers de toutes les
crises de certains de certaines bières
de certains conflits donc ce n'est pas
le commis de 19 qu'il avait un terme à
leur projet au contraire
donc oui il faut rester vigilant et et
ne pas ne pas oublier ceux
malheureusement cette menace qui pèse
qui est présente en france en europe et
en occident un activités policières et
judiciaires et moins intense dans cette
période de confinement est ce que on
pourrait faire face à une attaque plus
important dans ce contexte alors moi je
pense qu'ils sont l'activité judiciaire
- est moins importante certes mais ça ne
rentre pas en ligne de compte pour près
pour prévenir une attaque en revanche
les services antiterroristes internes et
extérieures sont son sens je pense aussi
solliciter les forces de l'ordre sont
sollicités les corps médical est très
sollicité donc moi je pense que ça
laisse ça peut laisser poser de présager
une d'autres d'autres attaques de ce
genre
effectivement et et à l'instar de ce qui
se passe dans le sahel de façon
moindre évidemment puisqu'on peut pas
comparer à des attaques type 13 novembre
dans des attaques des attaques de
groupes puisqu'il n'y a plus personne
aujourd'hui dans les rues ces groupes
jihadistes pour été profitez en traits
de cette faiblesse pour conduire de
nouvelles offensives selon vous alors
légaux les comptes extérieurs de auront
deux ont beaucoup de difficulté à
s'infiltrer on va dire entre guillemets
en europe puisque tout est fermé il ya
plus de vols les plus de ya plus de
moyens de franchir les frontières
à moins de le faire de façon très
clandestine par la mer par les airs
c'est fini à pied c'est possible
également mais ça demanderait beaucoup
de préparation ça devrait beaucoup de
temps beaucoup de de personnel en
revanche il y a des gens en france qui
peuvent passer individuellement à la
taxe en recevoir d'ordres puisque ils
ont adhéré à un projet islamiste depuis
très longtemps et il sombre
ils sont déjà conditionnés pour pouvoir
passer à la terre qu avec ce qu'ils ont
sous la main
là en l'occurrence il avait rien sous la
main il s'est servi dans un magasin et
le bilan est très lourd comme si on
avait besoin aujourd'hui d'avoir en plus
d'aider du commis de 19 des attaques
islamistes sur le territoire français ou
en europe
on a on n'aura peut-être pas d' attaques
du type 13 septembre
en revanche des actes isolés individuel
oui c'est très possible la preuve
est-ce que ce que vivent 19 leur
donnerait des arguments supplémentaires
certaines organisations terroristes par
d'un châtiment de dieu
ça fait partie de leur propagande oui je
les lui j'ai entendu effectivement tout
est bon tout témoin à prendre pour ces
personnes pour pour alimenter leur
propagande et à limoges alimenter leurs
projets et attirer à eux de nouveau
comment dirais-je de nouveaux fidèles
entre guillemets et moi je pense que
aujourd'hui tout est à l'arrêt tout et
tout est concentré toutes les forces et
c'est bien normal et sont concentrés sur
sur cette épidémie
en revanche il faut rester très vigilant
parce que je pense moi que une attaque
ou plusieurs attaques dans un dans une
ville ou dans un pays pourrait encore
plus désorganisé aujourd'hui c'est les
les
le corps médical et au bras du
oh et vous imaginez bien quand ils n'ont
pas besoin d'autres victimes causées par
des islamistes à la mi mars
l'organisation état islamique a exhorté
ses troupes à ne pas se rendre en europe
pour le diane en raison de cette
pandémie on indique que dans leurs rangs
une dizaine de morts
ça fait parti d'un risque diminué selon
vous en loin d'ailleurs les conflits ont
tendance à diminuer est ce que c'est le
cas également pour l'organisation état
islamique qui se calfeutre comme tout le
monde
alors évidemment moi je faut distinguer
deux choses dans cette danse est on va
dire dans cette branche dans cette
branche le l'état islamique et qui
effectue et un groupe quitte un groupe
islamiste parmi tant d'autres il a hélas
aujourd'hui sur la planète il va peines
qui sont capables de d'imposer la charia
d'imposer leur projet par là par la
violence les trois personnes qui va qui
va qui va s'infiltrer sur en europe
parce que l'europe est quand même
schengen les frontières de schengen sont
fermé toutes les frontières sont
contrôlés aujourd'hui il ya plus de
circulation donc cesser totalement
difficile effectivement ils vont rester
sur leur territoire mais encore une fois
c'est un projet qui n'a pas de
frontières c'est un projet qui a
commencé en 1928 aujourd'hui en france
en europe en angleterre il y a des
centaines de personnes voire des
milliers qui ont déjà adhéré au projet
intellectuellement et des idéaux
logiquement et certains sont prêts pour
pour comment dirais-je pour faire
avancer encore plus de projets à des
actions violentes ça fait ça fait ça
fait partie intégrante de leur leur
modus operandi c'est à dire que
l'idéologie et les l'idéologie en bout
de chaîne et en fin de chaîne il y a les
attaques violentes et ses attaques
violentes sont peuvent être portés par
n'importe qui n'importe quelle personne
qui se revendiquent de de ce projet
islamique de l'état islamique boko haram
de n'importe quel con qui s'applique
aujourd'hui sur sur sur la planète qui
est en activité et ils n'ont pas besoin
d'ordre de ils n'ont pas besoin de deux
commandos entre guillemets structuré qui
vont franchir des frontières comme on a
pu voir le malheureusement le 13
novembre
il ya quelques années aujourd'hui c'est
différent c'est sur le mondial sur les
théâtres d'opérations où il y a
toujours des opérations parce que je
vous rappelle qu'au sahel les forces
françaises malgré malgré cette épidémie
continue à apporter des coups très durs
au groupe aux groupes terroristes
islamistes qui a dans le sahel il n'a
ils n'ont pas stoppé leur comment
dirais-je il n'y a pas eu il n'ya pas il
pose dans cette guerre là on ira qu'ils
ont rapatrié dès des forces françaises
mais ça continue
est ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que la
préco vide va être très compliqué parce
que en afrique c'est pareil les les
forces africaines vont être touchés
également les africains malheureusement
vont être touchés également et en
afrique il ya une grosse grosse poche
dans dans les zones dans la zone
sahélienne mais aussi dans l'afrique de
l'ouest
il y a énormément de groupes islamistes
qui sont qui sont très actifs et qui
vont et qui vont profiter de cette
faiblesse entre guillemets pour pouvoir
[Musique]
mener d'autres notes l'attentât
heureusement merci beaucoup pierre
martinet d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur rt france